and without giving much away i can say
that there are
uh characters in the book who you do not
expect
to die and who do they are
your characters are extremely fragile um
it is one of the things that is most
was most exciting to me as a reader to
realize that
these characters who were following very
closely could be
maimed and that that and that those
scars would stay
they could be psychologically maimed and
transformed by those scars
and that would stick to the book and
they could die
however as magic seeps into this world
which is of course part of the unfolding
story
not even death is really um
permanent anymore what do you think
about that
uh well the i do think
that if you're bringing a character back
uh that every character has gone through
death
that's a transformative experience um
you know i mean even back in those days
of wonder man and all that i love the
fact that he died i don't think i was
although i liked the character uh in
later years i wasn't so thrilled when he
came back
because that sort of undid the power of
it and much as i admired tolkien
i've once again always felt that gandalf
should have stayed dead
i mean that was such an incredible
sequence in fellowship of the ring when
he
he faces the balrog on the bridge of
kazadoom and he falls into the gulf
and you know his last words are fly you
fools
and what power that had
uh what how how that grabbed me and then
he comes back as gandalf dwight and if
anything he's like sort of improved
but i never liked gandalf dwight as much
as gandalf the gray and i
never liked him coming back i think it
would have been a
even stronger story if tolkien had
left him dead um
my characters who come back from death
are
the worst for wear in some ways they're
not
even the the same characters anymore
uh the the body may be moving but some
aspect of the spirit is changed or or
transformed and they've they've
lost something one of the characters who
has come back repeatedly from death is a
minor character named eric dondarrion uh
the lightning lord and
and each time he's revived he loses a
little more of himself
and he was sent on a mission before his
first death he was sent on a mission to
do something and
and it's like that's what he's clinging
to and
he's forgetting other things he's
forgetting who he is or where he lived
he's forgotten the woman that he was
once supposed to marry
um bits of his humanity are lost every
time he comes back from death but he
remembers that mission
it's like his flesh is falling away from
him but this one
thing this purpose that he had is part
of what's
animating him and bringing him back to
death and i i think you see echoes of
that with some of the other characters
who have come back from death
but one one thing in the book which i
presume
is is made out of whole cloth
of imagination is is the religions of
this world
these are not religions of the of the
primary world that we live in the world
of uh
of your novels has several
major religions some minor sects the the
continent in which most of the
characters spend most of their time
have have two well-developed
uh religious philosophies within with a
a new sect that's coming to the
continent and gaining inroads
and i was just curious as to well how
does one sit down and
and create a religion
well um yeah the religions are
are made up religions and that's that's
imaginative religions but i i base them
all on
on actual real world religions just sort
of tweaking it
or expanding it a little i mean the the
faith of the seven
is of course based on the medieval
catholic church
and there's central doctrine that uh
there are there
is one god who has seven aspects
is partly based on the catholic
belief that there's one god but he has
three aspects you know father son and
holy ghost
and with the seven instead you have uh
you have the father the mother the the
maiden the crone the smith
the uh warrior and and the stranger
who's the uh
the death figure so um you know i
that's i think the general process for
for doing fantasy is you
you have to root it in reality but then
you then you play with it a little then
you add the imaginative element and then
you make it largely bigger
like the wall in my books of course was
inspired by hadrian's bowl which i
visited uh
on my first trip to the united kingdom
back in the early 80s
and we climbed to the top of hadrian's
wall and i i looked north
and tried to imagine what it's like to
be a roman soldier
stationed there you know in the first
century
at the end of the known world staring at
these distant hills and wondering
what lived there and what might come out
of it because you were you were looking
off the end of the world
protecting the civilized world against
whatever might emerge from those trees
of course what tended to emerge from
those trees were scots but
uh you know we couldn't use that so i i
made the wall considerably bigger and
uh made it made of ice you know that's
the process of uh
fantasizing because hadrian's wall i
think was made of lucite
originally